toss a coin to your witcher because
after a year and eight months of no
witcher content we are graced with a
standalone animated feature that is
actually pretty damn good it's good
really
yes the witcher nightmare of the wolf
tells the origin story of vesemir the
witcher who trained geralt and whose
character will play a large role in
season 2 of the live-action show so in a
lot of ways nightmare of the wolf is a
nice primer for this character as we
wait till december when the new season
arrives but this movie also has a ton of
cool easter eggs and connections to the
greater witcher universe that we'll be
taking a look at so pop a potion and oil
up your swords okay that sounded weird
and make sure to like and subscribe
because i'm always coming out with new
witcher content nightmare of the wolf
starts much like the witcher tv show
here we see an action-packed scene which
demonstrates our protagonist and what
they do kill monsters and collect coin
and this juxtaposition between vesamir
and geralt is fantastic because not only
does nightmare end on a young geralt but
it also sets up how these two characters
are similar vesimir will become a
father-like figure for geralt just like
geralt will become a father-like figure
for suri but it doesn't take long to
figure out how these two characters
differ in their flaws that thing that
holds them back as a character vesamir's
flaw is that he is too obsessed with
coin and riches coin's a real lover
more of her to pluck out there isn't
there in the first scene he couldn't
care less about the young boy whose
family was just slain by election
leaving the boy alone in the woods to
fend for himself while he takes off with
his reward he said practice your sad
face and maybe a passerby will offer you
a ride if vesemir is going to grow as a
character he will need to overcome his
flaw and learn there are things more
important than coin if you want to know
about geralt's flaw i suggest you check
out my witcher ending explained which
i'll leave a link to in the description
below the fight against the lesson also
known as a leschy or spriggan also
demonstrates three important witcher
techniques used to defeat monsters one
the ingestion of toxic potions which
grant the witcher powerful buffs two the
application of oils on weapons providing
additional benefits and three the use of
magical signs here we see vesimir
utilize the igni sign short for ignite a
powerful pyrokinetic blast the strange
thing about this battle with the lesion
is that the monster speaks and leshen
don't not only that it spoke alien a
language of the iron l elves which phil
evandrell calls a dead dialect linked to
ancient times you might remember
philevandril from the show when geralt
and yaskir encounter him living in
hiding in the throne room of the capital
of caidwin art carrick apologies if i'm
getting some of the pronunciations wrong
here sits king dagrad he's listening to
the plight of a mage by the name of
tetra who believes the witchers to be
creating monsters in order to muster
more work witchers after all are monster
hunters and the more monsters there are
the more coin they can collect but the
king takes the advice of one of his
advisors lady zerpst she's voiced by
mary mcdonnell which if you haven't seen
battlestar galactica go and watch
immediately bears
beats
battlestar galactica lady zerps doesn't
want to start a war with the witchers
and the king agrees unless there is more
evidence the case is closed and it
wouldn't be a witcher film without one
in a bathtub vesamir is here with
philavendral discussing the lesson's use
of an ancient tongue the elf has been
able to translate the lessons words
making out the phrase beware the den of
my dead philip andrew remarks on a mage
named kitsu who spoke alien and went
missing perhaps there's a link there's
also a fun line here where vesimir talks
about leaving the training of the young
ones to other witchers he doesn't care
about training them at all the irony
here is that he'll be the one to carry
on that torch and lead a new generation
of witchers at the end of the film we
flashback to get a look at vesimir as a
child the son of a poor family he dreams
of a life of riches and status where he
can build a life of his dream with his
friend and love interest ileana it's
here he also meets a witcher by the name
of diglin and gets a glimpse of the
witcher lifestyle diglin is strong
powerful and has a vast knowledge of
monsters vesimir watches as he makes
easy work of a demonic mar and even gets
to hold the hefty pouch of coins diglin
got for his work it's this pivotal
moment that entices vesimir to run away
from home and join the witchers he tells
ileana of his dreams excuse me for
wanting to be good at something other
than serving he talks about one day
being able to afford stylish armor buy
her a house and everything she desires
but what vesimir doesn't understand is
that life is more than coin all those
things shouldn't matter as long as he's
with her she says one of my favorite
lines to him so trade my debt to a
master i hate
with a debt to one that i love the scene
also foreshadows the film's tragic end
with besamir poking a dead wolf the wolf
represents vesimir the oldest living
member of the wolf school a specific
branch of witcher training wolves also
adore the witcher medallions back in
present day vesemir reads posters
proclaiming the evil ways of the
witchers witches are rogues without
virtue true diabolical creatures fit
only for killing tetra herself is of
pure human mage blood so you can see
here how they film comments on race
class and society there's a great edit
here when tetra talks about what it
takes to become a witcher and the shot
is a close-up of her eyes a nod to the
fact witcher's eyes turn to what carla
demecia crest in blood of the elves
calls those of a viper this also allows
witchers to see in the dark and refers
to part of their trials they endure as
youngsters to become witchers trials
which as we see in the film result in
many of the children being killed back
in vesemir's past we see a young witcher
trainee by the name of thomas crying
that's because he's been given to the
witchers via the law of surprise you'll
be familiar with this if you've read the
books or seen the television show the
law dictates that a man saved by another
is expected to offer to his savior a
reward whose nature is unknown to one or
both parties in geralt's case his
request for curing dunny was what you
find at home yet don't expect this would
end up being suri who at the time was
still in the womb of dunny's wife pavita
and dunny had no idea we get to see
first hand how brutal these trials are
for the kids with vesimir being one of a
few survivors to successfully undergo
them and become a witcher vesimir also
gets a crash course in mutagenic alchemy
when we're introduced to a mage by the
name of riedrick rietrich tells vesamir
about monsters mages made monsters then
made witches to kill them you see
redrick holds the secrets to combining
and creating monsters holding on to
these secrets so other mages don't make
the mistakes of the past the irony here
is that he and diglin are using them for
their own greed vesimir receives a
letter from miliana telling him his
parents have been killed and she has
come under the protection of a noble
family in caidwin we'll later find out
that lady zerps the woman we saw as an
adviser to the king is in fact ileana at
70 years old vesimir however looks like
he hasn't aged and that's because
witchers age much slower than regular
humans there's a fun line where three
witchers esko lambert and remus are
mentioned at least two of these witchers
eskel and lambert have been confirmed
for season 2 of the witcher and we've
actually seen remus at the beginning of
episode 3 in season 1. he's the guy who
gets killed by astriga so at this point
in nightmare of the wolf he would still
be alive vesamir and luca get in a fight
with some local knights and end up being
jailed for defending themselves however
it is ileana who comes to vesemir's aid
saying that if he can slay the beast
that has been plaguing the woods
surrounding the capital he can be set
free the only problem is he'll have to
be accompanied by the witcher-hating
tetra while camping tetra mentions two
important things number one chaos the
force which can be harnessed by mages
and to a lesser extent witchers to use
magic the second and more important is
her story about a priest who hired a
witcher to kill a troublesome girl as
we'll find out later this girl was her
mother killed at the hands of a witcher
in exchange for coin so we can see where
tetra's motivations are coming from when
it's revealed she's the big baddie she
only sees witchers as money hungry
devoid of any virtue and to some extent
she's right we also learned that tetra
was trained at artusa the same place we
saw yennefer train in season one on
their journey they encounter kitsu the
missing mage who seems to have been
overtaken by a demonic mar just like
that woman from vesamir's childhood a
brief battle ensues in which kitsu
disappears in an illusion of an
avalanche take note of the yellow colors
of this illusion it'll be the same
colors we see in the illusions near the
end but more on that in a bit vesamir
and tetra come across an old elven
school which has been repurposed to a
garrison this is a subtle nod to the
human elven war in which elves were
driven from their homelands and into the
woods after the arrival of humans on the
continent here vesamir and tetra find
philavendral who believes the witchers
are making these monsters in order to
make more money we also see a young elf
girl who we'll find is kitsu's daughter
and that kitsu has been experimented on
using mutagenic alchemy combining her
with that of amar remember that tetra is
a human and thus would want to kill
these two l's but vesamir lets them go
he says to tetra of his decision it was
not a question of price
oh the witch has found his morals which
is the beginning of his character arc
changing by the end of the story we'll
see how a once virtuous money-hungry
witcher turns into a virtuous selfless
mentor so tetra brings proof that the
witchers have been conducting these
mutagenic experiments and the king gives
the order to invade care more the
problem here is that not all the
witchers like vesamir knew about these
experiments and now they're all going to
be exterminated vesamir even confronts
diglin saying we were created to kill
creatures like these not to make them
but dagelan argues that without monsters
their way of life is at risk stating the
only thing keeping men from hunting us
are the scarier beasts we keep away it's
a moral dilemma where dagen does have a
point if monsters don't exist and the
witchers aren't needed then what is to
stop the humans from killing them just
like they do the elves and other races
but before any more talk on the matter
can be had tetra arrives with an army of
men and other foul creatures culminating
in an epic battle within the grand hall
of cairmorne which if you haven't
checked out the witcher con inside
karamorn video i'll leave a link to that
in the description vesamir is touched by
kitsu where he's given a wave of dreams
showcasing his greed how he swindled
people and a life he could have had
should he have stayed with iliana this
is all an illusion however and he's able
to break free beehead tetra and stab
kitsu right through the chest or so we
think remember that yellow glow we saw
earlier well we have yet another
illusion where we find out vesamir
didn't behead tetra he beheaded riedrick
and he didn't stab kitsu but his love
ilyana and just as it looks like vesamir
is going to succumb to tetra's plans
she's taken out by daglan vesamir's
nightmare his nightmare of the wolf is
no dream but reality he killed the woman
he loves the other witchers are dead and
he's lost everything much like kitsu we
get one last look at her in fox form
before caramorn is destroyed vesamir
leads ileana to die in front of a lake
the place where she wanted to have a
house and live out her days it's a
bitter tragic ending as tetra told
vesimir about mages casting illusions
put on undesirable food made food
tastier
yet the aftertaste of the illusion
in this way vesimir's life has been one
big illusion where wealth is the most
important learning the hard way that he
was wrong that bitter taste but there's
one final thing to take care of the
young ones before daeglin's death he
asks of vessemir
make him
something more
better
besamir will end up tracking the young
ones and giving them the choice whether
to come with him and train as witchers
and among them is geralt of rivia for
those who are wondering geralt came to
kirmorn after being dropped there by his
mother the sorceress pissena but that
topic is for a different video so this
is a great little tie-in to tie this
over until season 2 of the witcher comes
out on december 17th what did you think
of the witcher nightmare of the wolf i
want to hear your thoughts in the
comments below thanks for watching
everyone i hope you'll like and
subscribe because i'll be covering all
of the witcher season 2. for more bad
takes you can also follow me on twitter
and instagram at thingstoryt until next
time remember daddy loves you very much
you